hallo mein name ist luca und meine
lieben zuschauer vor einigen tagen habe
ich bereits auf die verrücktesten stock
fotos reagiert
ja
ja das kam ziemlich gut bei euch an
deswegen habe ich heute wieder 20
verrücktes top fotos rausgesucht und ich
würde sagen wir fangen direkt mit dem
ersten foto und zwar ist das hier das
ist eine dame die am fluß sitzt und ein
huhn in der hand hält und dieses an
spuckt
erstes foto und ich frage mich schon ja
gar nichts mehr das hier ist das zweite
foto und zwar es ist ein typ der in
statt eines kopfes auf einem kuchen
schläft ja fragt ihr euch noch was
machen allerdings direkt weiter mit dem
dritten komischen foto das ich für uns
heute ausgesucht habe und es war es eine
person die in der waschmaschine ist und
die beste zeit seines lebens darin
verbringt
frage ich nichts aber wenn ihr denkt das
kann nicht noch verrückter werden dann
schaut euch dieses foto jahren
das ist ein typ im anzug mit seiner
nähmaschine und im hintergrund ist eine
op s truck abgrund heruntergestürzt
das hier ist ein kind das sich einen
barcode scanner an den kopf hält und ich
weiß nicht ob er sich gerade versucht
damit umzubringen aber das wird
höchstwahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren
machen wir weiter mit nächsten foto und
zwar sind drei tiger in einem whirlpool
keine ahnung ja ich weiß auch nicht
warum das hier ist eine afro
amerikanische schlange beim
bewerbungsgespräch
ich liebe diese serie jetzt schon und
dieser alte mann nutzt anstatt eines
fernglases einfach zwei toiletten rollen
ja
damit sieht man definitiv besser beim
nächsten foto weis ich wieder überhaupt
gar nicht was da irgendwie der sinn von
sein soll uns war es eine salami in
einer banane
und das hier mal ganz kurz reingeschoben
das ist ein mann der auf eine photoshop
wurde und meine damen und herren in der
letzten folge hatten wir auch zwei
kartoffel bilder und zwar einmal eine
weibliche person die aussieht wie hitler
die kartoffeln schält und einmal eine
person die am schreibtisch sitzt und
sagt nee ich will keine kartoffel und
heute haben wir wieder kartoffel hass
und zwar der rechte will dem hier eine
kartoffel geben aber nein er will die
kartoffel nicht
das hier ist ein mann verkleidet als
high und im hintergrund brennt gerade
irgendwas ab fragt ihr euch noch
irgendwas von hier sitzt ein hund allein
an der bar mit seinem aschenbecher und
einem glas weißwein
also ich frag mich gar nichts mehr fährt
ein vater mit seinem sohn autoscooter
allerdings ist irgendwie auch noch ein
bus auf der autoscooter fläche
alles klar und hier schiebt sich einmal
eine banane durch seinen hinterkopf
ja da braucht man nichts mehr zu sagen
sie kuschelt einfach mit ihrem re im
bett und dieser typ wurde gerade von der
polizei festgenommen hat am ganzen
körper irgendwelche katzen kleben
hat
frag mich nichts mehr und ich weiß dass
sie das mittlerweile schon wisst ich das
jetzt auch schon oft genug gesagt habe
aber jetzt kommen wir zum letzten foto
ich dass es euch einfach unkommentiert
kurz hier ein paar sekunden eingeblendet
ja keine ahnung und es hätte mich das
heutige jetzt auch beenden meine lieben
freunde wenn euch meine zweite action
mittlerweile auf diese komischen stock
fotos gefallen hat das unbedingt einen
daumen hoch unter dem video ihr da
schreibt immer unten in die kommentare
ob ich noch einen dritten teil dazu
hochladen sollen abonniert main kanal
falls sie noch kein teil der luxus das
ist kostenlos und verpasst keine videos
mehr die hand gaben
[Musik]